[Música]
y el silencio
y obscuridad
esto me recuerda estar parado en el
túnel antes de salir a jugar uno de los
partidos más importantes de mi vida
méxico contra sudáfrica en el
mundial-2010 de sudáfrica
pero antes de contarles de seguirles
contando esta historia me gustaría
decirles cómo fue que llegué ahí era un
25 de diciembre
la tradición juntarnos en casa mis
padrinos a festejar la navidad como
también en una tradición jugar la
cáscara de los primos los primos chicos
contra los primos grandes desde aquel
entonces yo ya dejaba ver cosas que
otros niños no dejaban ver con su fútbol
y para no hacerles la historia más larga
les voy a decir la historia que cambió
mi vida la jugada que cambió mi vida
recuerdo que estábamos jugando y yo vi a
mi primo que tiene balón por allá y de
repente digo pásame la pasarela antes de
recibir el balón walk que como era una
costumbre que tenía cuando jugaba y me
encontré con mi primo grande el que era
durísimo es el si sabía dar patadas no
como yo
y recuerdo haberle pedido el balón
entonces yo le hice un movimiento de
cintura a mi primo mi primo se ha
quedado tirado la recibí por la pierna
izquierda me di la vuelta para acá y
cuando volteé vi la portería enorme y
dije no bueno tengo que patear no tengo
otra oportunidad yo recuerdo que para ti
con esta pierna con la izquierda por la
que ve hasta me cuesta trabajo subirme
al camión
en ese momento cuando impacte el balón
sabía que lo había hecho perfecto veía
cómo se movía la pelota perfecto iba
lento es que debe repetirse esto es
magia el balón iba lento lento en la
portería estaba mi primo al cual le
decíamos el maletero la tierra las manos
tan largas que cuando se quiso estirar
fue imposible que alcanzar el balón en
ese momento yo seguía la trayectoria y
me preparaba para empezar el festejo
empecé a correr y si yo seguirá en todo
en cámara lenta y de repente gritan
aguas voltea mi abuela
digo en la torre entonces como es en
todas las cáscaras el que la abuela va
por el balón imagínense el trayecto que
tuvo que hacer para llegar a pedirle una
disculpa a mi abuela fue el trayecto más
largo de mi vida llegué ahí
llegué ahí y ya estaba mi abuela con la
pelota en las manos y yo le voy a decir
perper te elegí abuela te pido una
disculpa fue un golazo dice gerardo no
te preocupes yo sé que es parte del
juego me agarró de las manos con un
cariño inusual después de haber recibido
sendos balonazo
y me dijo gerardo quiero hacerte una
pregunta
sí claro
ya sabes qué vas a hacer cuando seas
grande yo me quedé en un blanco
usted luego lo tenía bastante claro le
agarré las manos y le dije sí abuela voy
a terminar la primaria y después de que
termine la primaria me voy a dedicar a
ser futbolista profesional
y ahora todos los ojos de la familia
estaban sobre mí asombrados pero no por
el regaño que me había dado mi abuela
por haber recibido usando balonazo sino
porque un niño de 10 años tuviera tan
claro que quería hacer cuando fuera
grande esto me lleva a una frase que un
día un muy buen amigo me dijo
hay dos días que son los dos los dos
días más importantes de nuestra vida
el día que nacemos
y el día que descubrimos para que
nacimos
el día en que nacimos y el día en que
descubrimos para que nacimos
pues hoy estando aquí para me gustaría
preguntarte si ya sabes para qué estás
aquí para qué estás aquí si ya sabes
cuál es tu propósito si lo tienes claro
y si no lo tienes claro no te preocupes
con él conozco muchísima gente grande
que hasta la fecha no sabe cuál es el
propósito está bien el chiste es estar
siempre en búsqueda a encontrarlo
otro de los puntos que me ayudó mucho
durante mi vida y durante mi carrera fue
haber sido y seguir siendo un loco
soñador
me acuerdo que tenía 15 años bueno ahí
estoy un poquito más chiquito
había tenido la oportunidad de haberme
ido a estudiar a eeuu porque mis papás
me habían mandado un internado
yo me había hecho en la escuelita del
américa
todos tenemos errores
pero bueno estábamos preparándonos para
jugar un partido un torneo muy
importante y el director de fuerzas
básicas me llamó a su oficina y me dijo
gerardo necesito platicar contigo bueno
está emocionadísimo yo llegué a la
oficina me senté de repente estaba ahí
me dijo gerardo te hemos seguido durante
estos dos meses que has estado aquí y
vemos que has perdido talento y que ya
no tienes cualidades creemos que no
tienes la capacidad para llegar a ser
futbolista profesional
pero para mí fue un durísimo golpe una
gran sorpresa y saliendo hadi simoes
oficina y cuando salí me dije nunca nada
ni nadie se interpondrá en que yo pueda
cumplir mis sueños estuve mucho tiempo
enojado con ese señor pero hoy estoy
súper agradecido con él porque cada vez
que me pasa algo en la vida y veo que un
sueño se me va a truncar o se está
desviando me acuerdo es el momento y
regreso y me impulsa para seguir
peleando y luchando por mis sueños en
esos en ese mismo año
tuve la oportunidad de que me invitaran
mis papás por mis 15 años a un viaje
recuerdo entrar al estadio donde se iba
a jugar en el mundial del 94 el mejor
que irlanda recuerdo como los irlandeses
cantaban yo sea bueno la porra es
potentísima pero los irlandeses
cantabria no estos y son grandes ligas y
de repente los mexicanos respondían con
una porra pero todo era perfecto la
organización de la fifa esté como
calentaba los jugadores empezamos a
escuchar el himno y nos paramos y lo
cantamos muy emocionados con ellos
y yo desde ahí empezaba a visualizar
todo pero habría otra jugada que no
sería mía pero si se me quedaría muy
marcada y sería un parteaguas para mi
carrera y fue ésta
[Aplausos]
y si yo creo que todos nos emocionamos
cuando vimos uno de los goles de luís
garcía
yo estaba en el estadio y decía bueno
qué golazo y lo empecé a vivir muy de
cerca y lópez y lo empecé a vivir como
si estuviera dentro del campo de juego
después de 8 años
pasaría esto
[Música]
y bueno lo veo y me sigo emocionando se
pone se me sigue poniendo la piel
chinita
bueno bueno sí pero lo más importante
ahí fue que yo si así luis garcía lo
pudo haber hecho y yo lo empecé a
visualizar con tanta con tantas ganas y
con tanta potencia yo sabía que lo voy a
conseguir igual y que nada ni nada en el
camino sin interponer claramente no es
con una varita mágica no en base a
esfuerzo y disciplina pero eso ya se los
contaré después
hubo hay una anécdota muy buena
a un entrenador al cual estimo mucho un
día me dijo gerardo algún día te vi
jugar pelón y me encantó como imponía te
veías fuerte te veías con una gran
presencia y yo le compré esa creencia
fue una creencia súper potente u otras
creencias limitantes pero esta era súper
potente de hecho ahí saqué de ahí saqué
mi lema en el fútbol que decía así bueno
uno de tantos decía o pase el balón o
pase el hombre nunca pasan los dos
y después de tanto tiempo me dejé un
poco lo que les quiero decir es que no
importa si éste es greñudo
este es pelón porque yo algún día tuvo
el pelo grandote no importa este es
greñudo éste es pelón si tienes claros
cuáles son tus sueños ve y pelea por
ellos y lucha por ellos entonces hoy me
gustaría preguntarte que estás soñando
como lo está soñando cómo se siente de
haber conseguido ese sueño
el tercer punto que también fue un punto
un punto muy importante fue
estás dispuesto a sacrificarse y
esforzarte al máximo
yo salí de los pumas ay de ute y una
gran lección que me dio un preparador
físico recuerdo que estábamos en un
entrenamiento de primera división y
había que correr 10 metros entonces
había que correr a gran velocidad de
regreso de un ejercicio cansado pues yo
lo estaba haciendo
como todos mis compañeros acabó el
entrenamiento y me llamó el prepador
físico me sentó al lado de él y me dijo
gerardo como entrenas te eligió bien
súper bien estoy muerto no no lo hiciste
a la intensidad que yo te lo había
pedido
imagínate que tú tienes que correr la
intensidad y a la velocidad que yo te
pedí para salvar un gol y no no lo vas a
poder hacer porque no lo hiciste durante
el entrenamiento
en pumas entrenamos en la cancha 2 y
tenemos que bajar un gran camino al
estadio y me fui reflexionando toda esa
caminata solo
tiene mucha razón el preparador físico
y entonces a partir de ese día en mi
vida dije cuando hagas una cosa
hazla con el corazón en las manos da lo
mejor de ti y esfuérzate al máximo
tuve la fortuna de jugar 5 años en
europa pero para llegar a jugar 5 años
en europa no todo fue tan fácil y no
todo fue color de rosa
recuerdo haberme ido a hacer una prueba
al real madrid si en aquel entonces yo
ya era seleccionado nacional y estaba
dispuesto a tocar puertas toqué muchas
de acuerdo que estuve en el real madrid
se entrene dos semanas no tuve la
oportunidad de quedarme y cada vez que
me cerraban la puerta para mí era una
motivación extra para dar un esfuerzo
mayor y seguir creciendo en todos los
sentidos estuvo en portugal estuve dos
semanas no me quedé hasta que tuve la
oportunidad de llegar al tenerife y
gracias a que todas esas puertas que se
me cerraron me hicieron ser mejor y
todos los días yo iba creciendo y me iba
fortaleciendo y cuando llegué a tenerife
sabía que está en mejor nivel y me pude
quedar después de haber hecho una prueba
y también durante mi carrera y durante
mi vida
ha habido momentos bien difíciles y
decisiones bien complicadas yo jugaba en
el ejido en segunda división y mi sueño
máximo era jugar en primera división en
ese entonces jugaban figuras de la talla
mundial como figo zidane
ronaldinho beckham yo quería estar
compitiendo con ellos recuerdo que
estaba preparando en una cena una pasta
en mi casa y de repente esta no mi
teléfono
y ser un poco viejo
y recuerdo que era mi representante y me
dice gerardo te tengo una super noticia
por favor dime la después de tantos años
y tantos meses de sacrificio hay un
equipo de primera división que te está
siguiendo y ese equipo es el sevilla
solo quieren ver la última prueba de
fuego
el partido contra el atlético de madrid
es tu prueba final para que te contraten
bueno yo estaba feliz eje ok perfecto
gracias le cuelgo me voy otra vez a
preparar mi pasta repente y bueno voy a
empezar a preparar todas mis semanas
para llegar lo mejor posible llegó a la
computadora
y de repente veo empiezo a ver los
calendarios
hay un foco rojo y la boda de mi hermana
fue meses semanas y días sin dormir
claramente era el día más importante
para mi hermana y para mí también porque
soy parte de su familia
pero durante tantos años había trabajado
para conseguir lo que quería que era
jugar en primera división y era un
momento de tomar una decisión muy
complicada recuerdo que ya había pedido
permiso para viajar tenía mi boleto
deben comprar y un día antes con el
corazón en la mano
le hablé a mi hermana y le dije
va a ser lo siento terriblemente no
podré ir a tu voz
y hasta la fecha
hasta la fecha cuando lo platicamos no
seguimos emocionando y nos seguimos
bueno no lo que festejemos no pero este
lo seguimos recordando es bueno yo con
con un cariño especial
y por último que fue muy importante en
mi carrera también
siempre después de esa plática con el
prepador físico tuvo una rutina y fue
una rutina muy especial para mí y
después de tanto tiempo la rutina te
cuesta trabajo pero después de tanto
tiempo se convirtió en un hábito y
después de convertirlo en un hábito
logré que se convirtiera en una virtud
entonces será el primero en llegar una
hora antes que todos mis compañeros
porque tener una rutina especial
entrenaba con todos y al final me
quedaba una hora después porque tenía
una rutina especial o una virtud
especial que era empezar a preparar mi
entrenamiento para el día siguiente y
eso me hizo poder llegar a donde llegue
jugar 20 años de carrera
jugar 3 mundiales y ser hoy en día bueno
ya me pasaron pero ser el tercer el
cuarto jugador con más partidos juegas
con la selección mexicana de fútbol
porque siempre estuve dispuesto a
sacrificarme y dispuesto a dar lo mejor
de mí en cada momento
entonces hoy estando aquí parado me
gustaría preguntarte cada vez que te vas
a dormir te estás
me gustaría que te hicieras esta
pregunta estoy siendo mejor que ayer
como lo estoy logrando
y eso para mí fue muy potente
y ahora para terminar me gustaría
invitar a un a un amigo muy especial
bueno en verdad es mi hijo
[Aplausos]
esto
significa muchísimo en mi carrera
y les voy a contar brevemente cómo fue
que lo consigue jugamos un partido
méxico contra italia antes de jugar el
mundial del 2010 yo ese día viajo a un
gran partido se me acercó el entrenador
y me dijo gerardo te has ganado portar
el gafete
buenísimo me dice no te han logrado
portar el gafete en el partido inaugural
de méxico contra sudáfrica en el mundial
del 2010
para mí fue
de las mejores cosas que me ha pasado la
vida y me dijo te lo has ganado en base
a tu talento en base a tu disposición en
base a tu esfuerzo a tu perseverancia y
a tu disciplina
si bien es cierto que para mí este
gafete
significa mucho y fue un momento
memorable en mi carrera hoy estando aquí
hero y mis hijas ahí junto con mi mujer
quisiera decirte a ti ya todos ustedes
que aunque no haya un símbolo físico
siempre tendrán el poder de ser el
capitán de su propio destino de su vida
[Aplausos]